corona solidarität und krisenherde in
ihrer sommer pk band die bundeskanzlerin
vor einer spaltung der gesellschaft
gericht kippt demo verbot gegner der
korona vorschriften dürfen morgen in der
hauptstadt protestieren und die große
schau von donald trump wo der
us-präsident feiert sich als retter der
nation und ist jetzt offiziell
präsidentschaftskandidat der
republikaner
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sportstandort von
mir
es bleibt ernst so die bundeskanzlerin
heute bei ihrer traditionellen
sommerpressekonferenz sie bedankte sich
für das umsichtige verhalten der bürger
machte aber auch klar dass der kampf
gegen das virus im herbst und winter
noch schwieriger werde
für die kommenden monate nannte sie drei
zentrale schwerpunkte kinder dürften
nicht die verlierer der pandemie werden
ihre bildung müsse mit das
allerwichtigste sein
die wirtschaft müsse so weit wie möglich
am laufen gehalten oder wieder zum
laufen gebracht werden und den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt gelte es
so weit wie möglich zu wahren
david gebhard was den auftritt der
kanzlerin vor den hauptstadtjournalisten
zusammen es ist sommer pk auftritt
nummer 15 der bundeskanzlerin für ihr
masken aufbewahrung station ist es
auftritt nummer eins die
hauptstadtpresse hält hygiene abstand im
jahr der korona pandemie die laut merkel
eine nie dagewesene herausforderung ist
wir werden noch länger mit diesem virus
leben müssen und deshalb ist meine
grundhaltung eine der wachsamkeit der
aufmerksamkeit gerade jetzt da die
infektionszahlen wieder so deutlich über
die letzten wochen gestiegen sind
es ist ernst unverändert ernst und
nehmen sie es auch weiterhin ernst
eine rückkehr zur normalität sei erst
möglich wenn es einen wirksamen
impfstoff oder ein medikament gebe
solange dürften kinder nicht die
verlierer der pandemie seien
wirtschaftsleben und gesellschaftlicher
zusammenhalt müssten aufrechterhalten
werden merkel rechtfertigt so eine
komplette kehrtwende in ihrer
haushaltspolitik
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass das
eine gute entscheidung ist sich jetzt in
hohem maße zu verschulden weil alles
andere uns noch viel länger in der
sozusagen kralle der pandemie halten
würde
in der außenpolitik warnt merkel unter
anderem russland vor einer einmischung
in belarus fordert aufklärung im fall
dabei
wir werden auch das versuchen wenn wir
mehr klarheit haben über die
hintergründe
ähnlich wie man dass er bei hans
kripperl hatte dann auch durchaus eine
europäische reaktion zu haben genau fünf
jahre ist es her dass merkel an gleicher
stelle inmitten des flüchtlings sommers
den wohl umstrittensten satz ihrer
amtszeit sagte wir haben so vieles
geschafft wir schaffen das im großen und
ganzen stehen sie zu den entscheidungen
von damals sagt sie heute
speziell hier also geschafft hat mich ja
eigentlich nichts aber gefordert hat
mich sicherlich vieles es ist insgesamt
für sie kein tag für selbstkritik merkel
gibt die krisenkanzlerin in der wohl
vorletzten sommer pk ihrer amtszeit in
der vieles ritual war und manches ganz
anders theo koll in berlin was war ihr
eindruck von der kanzlerin nun der
eindruck war wie die korona lage ernst
und so sollte es wohl auch wahrgenommen
werden als merkels mahnung an die
menschen die sorge über die weitere
entwicklung war ja deutlich anzumerken
sie nimmt diese pandemie sehr ernst
nicht nur als körperliche sondern auch
als gesellschaftliche gefahr
die kanzlerin warnt vor einer spaltung
der gesellschaft einige gruppen seien
deutlich stärker betroffen als andere
sie nannte insbesondere familien kinder
ältere künstler der auftritt heute war
eine art auftakt ins letzte jahr der
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel und zu
erleben war deshalb eine kanzlerin in
ihrem politischen herbst die besorgt auf
den pandemischen herbst und auch winter
blickt dankeschön für diese einschätzung
nach berlin theo koll war das wie es in
teilen der gesellschaft brodelt auf
welchen widerstand und unmut die korona
regeln aufstoßen zeigt sich bei den
protestmärschen in berlin
die dürfen morgen nun doch stattfinden
die berliner richter sehen keinen grund
für ein verbot
das land hatte die demo vor zwei tagen
mit der begründung untersagt dass dort
erfahrungsgemäß die vorgaben zum hygiene
schutz nicht eingehalten
würden beim letzten mal am ersten august
waren 30.000 menschen gekommen
ein großteil von ihnen ohne maske aus
berlin sylvia bleßmann und marcus groß
berlin steht ein protest wochenende
gegen die korona politik bevor die
ersten demonstranten sind schon da
sammeln sich vorm brandenburger tor noch
bis zum mittag stand ein ganzes camp der
kritiker mitten in berlin
nun wissen sie dass sie bleiben und
demonstrieren können das
verwaltungsgericht hat das demo verbot
gekippt für ein verbot hat das gericht
keine hinreichende grundlage gesehen
hintergrund ist dass das
versammlungsgesetz eine unmittelbare
gefahr für die öffentliche sicherheit
fordert der veranstalter hat hier ein
hygiene konzept vorgelegt dieses hygiene
konzept sieht vor dass die teilnehmer
den mindestabstand einhalten sollen
geklagt hatten die anmelder der größten
kundgebung am sonnabend sie hatten
22.000 teilnehmer angemeldet der
initiator zeigte sich erleichtert
ein phänomenaler sieg für die demokratie
in deutschland eine wirkliche klatsche
für die stadt berlin und für den
innensenator
das urteil ist noch nicht rechtskräftig
der innensenator prüft noch ob er gegen
die aufhebung seines verbots beschwerde
einlegen wird
dann wird das oberverwaltungsgericht
berlin brandenburg entscheiden und zwar
noch in den abend- oder nachtstunden
dreht es die entscheidung wieder wird
das bundesverfassungsgericht wohl über
die demonstration entscheiden müssen
es gibt über 100 angemeldete
demonstrationen noch zahlreicher aufrufe
von gewaltbereiten rechtsextremen
die polizei will auf den
gesundheitsschutz und die auflagen
permanent hinweisen und sie auch
durchsetzen
das gericht hat die einhaltung von
mindestabständen verordnet einem masten
pflicht gehört nicht zu den auflagen
3000 polizisten stehen bereit um die
demonstrationen abzusichern
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen in deutschland im durchschnitt
der vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 1330 menschen neu mit dem virus
angesteckt das sind so viele wie gestern
interessant dazu auch das politbarometer
antje pieper ist hier mit dem neuesten
zahlen guten abend steht die mehrheit
der befragten noch hinter den massnahmen
ja da gibt es eine klare mehrheit 60
prozent finden die geltenden maßnahmen
gerade richtig
mehr als jeder vierte fordert sogar dass
sie noch härter ausfallen müssten für
übertrieben hält die regelungen nur
jeder zehnte außerdem wollen die
allermeisten auch dass die maßnahmen
stärker kontrolliert werden
mehr als drei viertel der befragten
sprechen sich dafür aus nur 21 prozent
sind dagegen
auffallend ist dass stärkere kontrollen
die anhänger aller parteien mehrheitlich
gut finden wird die dfg sind sich uneins
jetzt ist es auch das erste
politbarometer seit dem olaf scholz von
der spd als kanzlerkandidat nominiert
wurde wie kommt da an also zunächst
finden die meisten anhänger aller
parteien dass olaf scholz eine gute wahl
ist für die spd und schaut man auf die
projektionen dann scheint sich das auch
zu bestätigen wenn am sonntag wirklich
bundestagswahl wäre dann käme die
cdu/csu unverändert auf 38 prozent die
spd könnte zwei punkte zulegen käme auf
16 prozent ihr bester wert seit april
die afg 9 die fdp 5 die linke käme auf 8
prozent alle unverändert und die grünen
liegen bei 19 prozent minus 2 dankeschön
antje pieper das ausführliche
politbarometer mit antje pieper konnten
sie im heute journal sehen um 10 und
wenn sie noch mal in ruhe nachlesen
möchten wie die deutschen zu den corona
maßnahmen stehen finden sie zahlen und
weitere grafiken auch online in unserer
zdf heute und jetzt noch zwei wichtige
personalien aus der politik die
parteivorsitzenden der linken katja
kipping und bernd riexinger geben ihre
ämter auf den rückzug kippings
bestätigte die bundesgeschäftsstelle der
linken in einem schreiben an die
parteigremien habe kipping mitgeteilt
dass sie beim erfurter parteitag in rund
zwei monaten nicht wieder kandidieren
werde und nach zdf-informationen wird
auch riexinger nicht wieder für das amt
kandidieren beide hatten den
parteivorsitz 2012 gemeinsam übernommen
im fall des ungeklärten feuertodes des
asylbewerbers oury jalloh haben die
externen sonder gutachter des landtags
in sachsen anhalt ihren bericht
vorgelegt von der festnahme bis zu
dessen tod seien die polizei laufen die
polizeilichen maßnahmen fehlerhaft oder
rechtswidrig gewesen
der mann aus sierra leone war vor 15
jahren in einer dessauer polizeizelle
gestorben
zuvor soll er seine matratze selbst
angezündet haben woran es aber
erhebliche zweifel gibt die genauen
umstände des todes konnten auch in zwei
gerichtsverfahren nicht geklärt werden
zur demokratiebewegung in belarus die eu
erhöht jetzt den druck auf das land und
hat sanktionen gegen ranghohe
unterstützer von staatschef lukaschenko
beschlossen
ihnen werden wahlbetrug und gewalt gegen
friedliche demonstranten vorgeworfen
vergangene nacht wurden in belarus
wieder mehr als 260 menschen
festgenommen
auch ein kamerateam des zdf wurde
stundenlang festgehalten
christian senn berichtet unser zdf
kamerateam filmt gestern abend an einer
straßenecke in minsk plötzlich werden
sie festgenommen
so geht es noch um 50 anderen
journalisten unser team wurde mehrere
stunden auf einer polizeistation
festgehalten trotz gültiger
akkreditieren
die handys wurden ihnen abgenommen in
der nacht kamen sie wieder frei
unversehrt lukaschenko erhöht den druck
auf medien und demonstranten
man muss auf die straße gehen bis all
diese willkür endet bis man aufhört
friedliche bürger zu terrorisieren und
ich betone es friedlich
europa schaut besorgt auf die lage in
belarus in berlin heute treffen der eu
außenminister mit sanktionen gegen
ranghohe unterstützer von lukaschenko
wollen sie den machthaber zum einlenken
bewegen wenn herr lukaschenko den druck
auf die friedliche zivilbevölkerung
aufhören lukaschenko erhöhen
wir arbeiten an einer sanktionsliste die
alsbald verabschiedet werden soll
und lukaschenko der besuchte heute eine
käsefabrik das eu-land litauen hätte
belarus gerne sofort mit sanktionen
belegt lukaschenko droht dem nachbarland
schauen wir mal wer wem noch angst macht
wir zeigen ihnen mal was wirkliche
sanktionen sind
ich habe die regierung beauftragt zu
prüfen sämtliche handelsströme von den
litauischen häfen auf andere umzulenken
die menschen in belarus wollen auch am
wochenende wieder zu tausenden friedlich
auf die straße gehen
gegen lukaschenko und für ihre freiheit
nicht nur belarus auch der türkei drohen
die eu außenminister heute mit
strafmaßnahmen grund ist der streit mit
griechenland wegen türkischer erdgas
bohrungen im östlichen mittelmeer die
betrachtet brüssel als unrechtmäßig
allerdings ist in der eu umstritten wie
stark in dem konflikt auf sanktionen
gesetzt werden soll
die deutsche regierung bemüht sich um
eine diplomatische lösung
der langjährige japanische
ministerpräsident aber hat aus
gesundheitlichen gründen seinen
rücktritt eingereicht der 65-jährige
sagte er werde so lange im amt bleiben
bis ein nachfolger fest stehe aber dass
amtszeit war von großer politischer
stabilität geprägt zuletzt war jedoch
wegen seines umgangs mit der korona
krise in die kritik geraten
in die usa gut zwei monate vor der
präsidentenwahl dort ist das land tief
gespalten gezeichnet von krone und
sozialen unruhen donald trump stellt
sich jetzt offiziell noch mal zur wahl
bei seiner nominierungs rede
präsentierte er sich als präsident für
recht und ordnung sein demokratischer
herausforderer joe biden
dagegen hatte bei seiner rede vor einer
woche versprochen das land wieder zu
einen
sollte beiden gewinnen so waren jump
droht dem land chaos anarchie und
wirtschaftlicher niedergang über den
auftritt des präsidenten berichtet heike
slansky
eine bombastische kulisse der präsident
lädt ins weiße haus um die nominierung
seiner partei anzunehmen eigentlich
nicht erlaubt aber das interessiert hier
niemanden auch nicht den präsidenten der
sich doch recht und ordnung auf die
fahne geschrieben hat seinen
herausforderer stellt er als eine gefahr
fürs land dar
beiden ist nicht der retter von amerika
seele
er ist der zerstörer von jobs und wenn
er die chance bekommt wird er der
zerstörer der amerikanischen
großartigkeit seien mehr als 1500 gäste
die dem präsidenten zu jubeln kaum
masken kein abstand als gäbe es keine
pandemie an der immer noch rund 1000
amerikaner täglich sterben und trotzdem
niemand könne ihm das wasser reichen er
habe die stärkste wirtschaft aller
zeiten geschaffen die steuern gesenkt
china die stirn geboten
dies ist die wichtigste wahl der
geschichte unseres landes
diese wahl wird entscheiden ob wir den
amerikanischen traum retten oder ob wir
einer sozialistischen agenda erlauben
unser geschätztes schicksal zu zerstören
der präsident als angstmacher ein fest
für die fact checker die rede gespickt
mit unwahrheiten keine versöhnlichen
töne sein amerika kennt nur freund oder
feind
vier tage parteitag der republikaner
eine perfekte inszenierung zum finale
ein feuerwerk am himmel die
wahlempfehlung trump 20 20
matti wissen live aus washington das
droht ein schmutziger wahlkampf zu
werden oder ja der präsident hat sich
hier nicht als ein präsident für alle
amerikaner präsentiert sondern eher als
ein präsident für ein republikanisches
man könnte auch sagen ein traumschuss
amerika und damit er den gegner die
anderen dann eben als existenzielle
bedrohung darstellen kann hatte er eine
reihe von fakten mit vor allen dingen
dann etwa zwei dutzend lügen und
falschbehauptungen zusammengemischt ich
glaube er legt es in erster linie darauf
an dass er die bundesstaaten wieder
gewinnt die ja beim letzten mal gewonnen
hat er könnte sich sogar leisten zwei
dieser bundesstaaten nicht zu gewinnen
doch zu verlieren und er wäre am ende
immer noch der sieger
und wenn die beiden wirklich gegen
halten will dann glaube ich reicht es
nicht aus wenn er das von zu hause in
der wert sondern erst raus ins land
müssen den menschen klar machen dass er
ein präsident sein will
der für alle amerikaner dann das amt
übernehmen will
gerade im moment strömen tausende zum
marsch auf washington in erinnerung an
die rede von martin luther king i have a
dream
was ist das wichtigste anliegen dieser
demonstranten
ja ich glaube das wichtigste ist es dass
sie dem präsidenten und dem land klar
machen wollen dass die
lebenswirklichkeit von ihnen eine ganz
andere ist als donald trump sie in
seiner rede und der parteitag auch
geschrieben haben
es geht um soziale und wirtschaftliche
ungerechtigkeit im land es geht um
ungerechtigkeiten zwischen den rassen im
land und die enkelin von martin luther
king hat vorhin bei der rede gesagt es
ist jetzt höchste zeit dass dieser traum
von dem ihr großvater damals 1963 sprach
in erfüllung geht
ich glaube diese protestbewegung könnte
aber nur dann erfolg haben wenn sie in
den nächsten wochen weiterhin stark
öffentlich auftritt wenn sie es schafft
die gewalttäter zu marginalisieren
und wenn am ende sehr sehr viele
menschen am dritten november zur wahl
gehen dankeschön elmar theveßen live aus
washington nach deutschland zurück zu
einer wichtigen entscheidung des
landgerichts frankfurt
im prozess um die tödliche attacke auf
einen jungen muss der täter dauerhaft in
die psychiatrie
wegen psychischer probleme sei der 41
jährige schuldunfähig
trotzdem gehe von ihm eine große gefahr
für die allgemeinheit aus er hatte vor
rund einem jahr einen 8 jährigen und
dessen mutter im frankfurter
hauptbahnhof vor einen fahrenden zug
gestoßen
der junge starb die mutter überlebte und
jetzt ganz anderes thema in köln tummeln
sich in diesen tagen normalerweise
hunderttausende besucher bei der
gamescom der weltweit größten
computerspiele messe die gamer können
diesmal aber zu hause vor dem display
sitzen bleiben denn die neuesten spiele
highlights werden noch bis sonntag
komplett online vorgestellt kein großes
problem für die branche denn in der pro
monat zeit haben so viele menschen
gezockt wie noch nie
der bund will zudem deutsche
entwicklerstudios weiter fördern mit
insgesamt 250 millionen euro in den
kommenden jahren und jetzt sind wir beim
sport norbert und da steht die tour de
france fordert wir ja morgen geht's los
in nizza dieses jahr steht das größte
radrennen der welt ganz im zeichen von
corona weniger zuschauer weniger
stimmung abgeschirmte teams und fahrer
ja ein heiteres volksfest wird die tour
dieses jahr wohl nicht die côte d'azur
im wahrsten sinne des wortes ein hotspot
denn nicht nur am standort in nizza
steigen die fallzahlen was die große
schleife zur reise ins ungewisse werden
lässt geplant sind über 2500 corona
tests fällt positiv aus erfolgte aus
schluss kommt ein zweiter aus derselben
mannschaft hinzu wäre es das für das
ganze team wenn wir jetzt endlich
argumentieren würden vielleicht dann
doch nach einer woche schon verweist
oder wie hoch die gefahr ist dass immer
thematisieren würde es bringen die
sportler nicht weiter das bringt uns
nicht weiter
wir versuchen einfach die sportler und
auch das personal zu schützen
von der öffentlichkeit sind sie so gut
es geht abgeschottet auch wenn zuschauer
in begrenzter zahl erlaubt sind genießer
sind es nur 50 an start und ziel
die gewohnten massen in den bergen soll
es ebenfalls nicht geben
aus deutscher sicht ruhen die hoffnungen
auf emanuel buchmann vom team bohrer
hansgrohe das seinem sturz bei der
dauphiné rundfahrt ist er jedoch immer
noch gehandicapt nichts anbrennen läuft
also ich denke ich schon dass ich auf
gesamtwertung fahren will aber muss man
jetzt von tag zu tag einfach mal schauen
wie es geht
sie würde sicherlich seien erst einmal
ohne ausfall durch die erste woche
zukommt zur formel 1 beim zweiten freien
training zum großen preis von belgien in
spa ist heute red bull pilot max
verstappen tagesbestzeit gefahren
satte zwei sekunden dahinter sebastian
vettel mit seinem ferrari auf einem
enttäuschenden 17 platz auf dem
hochgeschwindigkeitskurs von spa
entdeckt sebastian vettel irgendwie die
langsamkeit der viermalige weltmeister
im ferrari mit großen problemen leistet
sich einige verbremser es verdichten
sich zudem die wechselgerüchte schon
länger wird vettel mit racing point in
verbindung gebracht der klare favorit
für dieses siebte saisonrennen mercedes
pilot lewis hamilton auf seiner
habenseite stehen bereits vier siege am
nachmittag landete der weltmeister auf
rang drei schnellste heute max
verstappen den niederländer im red bull
fast zwei sekunden schneller als vettel
zwei sekunden das ist schon eine welt in
der formel 1 muss man sogar zum wetter
derzeit noch wer zeit und noch das
gesamte wochenende gelten
unwetterwarnungen für weite teile
südbayerns und angrenzende gebiete baden
württembergs mehr dazu gleich von ostern
christian sievers freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um 22 uhr und hier
übernimmt morgen petra gerster ich hatte
heute bisschen knoten in der zunge
das bedingt zu entschuldigen wünsche
ihnen aber auf jeden fall ein
unbeschwertes wochenende auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ergiebiger
dauerregen wird erwartet vor allem im
süden deutschlands aber auch in der
alpenregion
das liegt an diesem kleinen tief was
sich entwickelt und allmählich in unsere
richtung wandert ja und die regenmengen
sind sehr groß bis sonntag 200 liter auf
den quadratmeter auf der alpensüdseite
und am alpenrand sind es auch gut 100
liter auf den quadratmeter schauen denn
die nacht oder sehen sie im süden da ist
der regen schon und vor allem am
alpenrand auch teilweise mit gewittern
durchsetzt sonst gibt es einzelne
schauer
auch an der nordsee gewitter ist aber
nicht so heftig wie am alpenrand und die
temperaturen bei 8 bis 16 grad morgen im
tagesverlauf weiterer ergiebiger regen
ganz im süden und das hält den ganzen
tag an im nordwesten kommen neue schauer
auf ansonsten trockene abschnitte teils
mit sonnenschein in der mitte und im
osten die temperaturen dazu erreichen 24
grad im osten deutschlands und 15 grad
an den alpen und am sonntag setzt sich
der dauerregen im süden fort wandert
sogar noch ein bisschen nach nordosten
bei 14 bis 22 grad und danach wird es
ein wenig weniger damit ein schöner
abend